hi there Steve Kaufman and my third week
of the Polish challenge I just want to
update you on what I've been doing I
mentioned previously that i've been
using filters stories i think there are
a great introduction to the language not
only an introduction but a place where
you can go back and practice your
grammar in other words i see them as a
replacement for the teach yourself
colloquial similar sort of beginner
books and much much better because much
much more content repetition explanation
almost becomes unnecessary because you
repeat these patterns so many times and
then of course i'm going to go back to
them and really looking at if we can't
do something like that for other
languages at link however I've always
said you have to move to authentic
content as soon as you can so I've been
busying myself gathering authentic
content and one thing I look for e-books
polish ebooks I found this Red Alert
tell Ronie I left which is a book
written by Bill browser about his
experiences in Russia very popular book
which I've read in English I found the
audio book and the e-book at first I
couldn't none of the Polish sites would
allow me to download the book I that
somehow physically be in Poland and they
would physically send it to me but I
finally finally found one publio dot PL
basically I i went to google translate I
wrote you know I would like to buy an
e-book and download it is this possible
i live in canada i sent at about five of
these any of the ebook sites that had a
contact there and publio p a point PL
came back very quickly i came back very
quickly so i bought from them the e-book
i also bought an audiobook on polish
history i was also able to find an
e-book on polish history written by
Topolsky so I've started I've done about
five or six chapters of children e-alert
in Polish listening and reading creating
a lot of links i think my known words
total is now i've added about 8,000 new
words do I know works
total and I've linked 7,000 plus new
links at link so I'm a reading and I'm
listening and I'm linking and what else
yeah I boarded these books you know
paper books they haven't come yet but I
have more than enough material now plus
I listen to podcast like report or
report austin es top shotta which is a
podcast which i used to understand ten
fifteen percent oh now I'm up to fifty
sixty percent so I'm progressing in
terms of my vocabulary and my
comprehension am i speaking is nowhere
at sometime in early October i will
speak either with a tutor and linker
with twitter and we'll see just how poor
i am but I'm not worried because I know
from experience that if I continue to
work in my comprehension and my
vocabulary my familiarity with the
language that all of a sudden I'm going
to be able to start speaking with
difficulty of course but then I'll be
able to progress progress quite quickly
so there you have it thank you for
listening and I my next week I'm going
to be kind of tied up because I have a
good friends a couple from Sweden
visiting so we're going to be taking
them around in Vancouver take them out
to Whistler we're going to tour the
interior of the province so I think for
a week I don't know where I'll be able
to sneak in any polish but we will see
thank you bye for now and keep working
and and meet your targets read listen
link get at it okay and to send your
questions in bye